do you feel like you need to make big
time records to get the next generation
of kids to care about Diddy in the way
that I do I think it's going to pass
about caring about me personally I want
them to care about my brands care about
my businesses and also I want to care
about them do someone that you look to
and you say he's doing it right she's
doing it right
I've always been a big fan of Steve Jobs
I really look up to Michael Jordan and
Muhammad Ali people have a certain
certain work ethic am I gonna vote for
you one day no you're not gonna vote for
me why not um I just I just I just don't
like politics my hat goes off to Mayor
Bloomberg and President Obama and
everybody else that's out there even the
Republicans shout out to y'all too but
you know it's it's just uh I just I just
don't like it does rock nation make you
want to become a sports agent you love
or no no no I'm not I I love sports but
um I'm more of a of a owner type of guy
so I would you know I have aspirations
to become which it would it will happen
I will become the first in a film first
African American you know majority owner
not not having a small state but
actually owning an NFL team but then
when I see my friend you know having a
sports agency I support them and you
know when it when you know when I get
the calls or we need to do bad boy
sports I'm like no that's not that's not
my lane I stay in my lane this is this
is my lane that I want to do and you
know and and and I think that's um I'm
just me I don't I don't I don't you know
I do my own thing
why is your lane revolt TV why are you
doing this I saw the opportunity that
there was no ESPN of music so revolt
will be that it will be the number one
name in music so when you see Beyonce
having to go and do a concert special
for ABC or do a documentary there's a
reason for that there's because there is
no number one name there's no place in
music there's no place for her but is
what going to have
kind of deep pockets and budget that an
HBO or an ABC does to bring these kind
of big-time artists in no we will not
have those deep pockets we are startup
but we will have what they don't have is
the music credibility